I don't want to have a hundred guards
standing with rifles all over the school
you do a concealed carry permit but we
really do have to strengthen up really
strengthen up background checks we don't
want people that are mentally ill to be
having any form of weaponry the
Democrats are being totally unresponsive
they don't want to do anything about
daca I'm telling you and it's very
possible that docket won't happen North
Korea we imposed today the heaviest
sanctions ever imposed on a country
before President Trump at CPAC today
that speech was like catnip for that
crowd
it was the let Trump be Trump
essentially the folks who say he needs
to be unplugged and do those campaign
speeches they won the day because he did
and it was an hour and 14 minutes there
was a lot to unpack in that speech and
other news today but one of the big
items was North Korea sanctions and what
the administration is doing here's the
Treasury Secretary our actions target
shipping and trade companies vessels and
individuals across the world who we know
are working with North Korea's behalf we
are also issuing a global shipping
advisory in conjunction with the Coast
Guard and the State Department to put
everyone on notice of North Korea's
illicit maritime tactics and underscore
the significant sanctions risk of
engaging in maritime business with North
Korea it's already the most sanctioned
country in the world now more so from
the US point of view let's bring in our
panel byron york chief political
correspondent of the washington examiner
a besotted associate editor of Real
Clear Politics and host of No Labels
radio on Sirius XM and Jason Reilly Wall
Street Journal columnist and senior
fellow at the Manhattan Institute byron
let's start with North Korea significant
different tone big move today well not
to hear the President's speech I mean
this was a very very Trumpy speech and
it went all over the place and the
extraordinary
about the North Korea part of the
speeches he almost forgot to put it in
well the White House divisions were
touting it exactly they were saying here
comes here exactly they were in in the
lead-up to the speech they were saying
this is gonna be the big news she
listened an hour goes by an hour in ten
minutes he's wrapping up about to say
goodbye and he says Oh North Korea we're
gonna impose really strong sanctions
goodbye everybody but they they are
serious in the sense that these this is
another step and we often hear that
we've done everything we can do with
North Korea
we really haven't and these are
additional sanctions that might have an
effect
it also comes as Ivanka Trump lands in
South Korea with a specific message
obviously today with this sanctions
levying as as Mike Pence the Vice
President did not have a meeting with
the North Koreans when he was there
right
the timing is no accident Ivanka Trump
is there she's being hosted by president
moon of South Korea who has been trying
to engage the north but I think the
message from the White House's
engagement or no engagement on Olympics
or no Olympics we are going to continue
to put pressure on North Korea and we
saw last week of a media when Gaga over
the North Korean leaders sister being at
the Olympics and so forth Trump was
saying I don't care about that the White
House says we don't care about that
either we don't care about those
appearances this is a dangerous regime
trying to become a nuclear power and
we're gonna keep the pressure on we
haven't seen sanctions move the needle
that much we have seen some movement in
China but not as much as the US wants to
see but is this going to work well it's
always the question of whether or not
these are enforceable and the the the
regime in North Korea has so many ways
to criminal conduct to do runarounds and
workarounds of most of the sanctions
right now they're under pressure from
from sanctions on oil so there this is
why we're going after the shipping to
see you know what what kind of
workarounds there they have going there
there's always another country that's
willing to help them in the dark of
night the Chinese I think what the
administration has gotten the Chinese to
do so far if enforced is very
consequential this is very aggressive
and I think we should all give them a
lot of credit for that the answer to the
question whether or not
forcible and ultimately consequential we
don't know Myron you mentioned he did
have his campaign mojo today
it doesn't fit everybody's cup of tea
but it definitely fits it with the CPAC
folks and supporters throughout the
country in the middle of the country
especially those states here is on armed
guards did nothing earlier in the day
talking about down in Florida when it
came time to get in there and do
something he didn't have the courage or
something happened but he certainly did
a poor job I'd rather have somebody that
loves their students and wants to
protect their students then somebody's
standing outside that doesn't know
anybody and doesn't know the students
the teachers and the coaches and other
people in the building the Dean the
assistant dean the principal they can
they love that people they want to
protect these kids we think that's
classic Trump communication on guns he
did talk about background checks he
talked about
let's see mental health issues and but
the one thing he didn't talk about was
something he's actually been saying for
the past couple of days which is raising
the age to by a long gun to equal that
of a buying a handgun you have to be 21
to buy a handgun you can buy a long gun
like the ar-15 at 18 a lot of talk about
raising that to 21 the NRA doesn't like
it but the president has specifically
said in the last couple of days that he
does like the idea but he said nothing
about it out of this hour and 14 minutes
peach juice I think he has a good point
about the gun-free zones and targeting
the mass shooters targeting this I mean
there's a reason you don't get a lot of
mass shootings at NRA conventions for
example even among mentally ill people
they seem to know better so there is
there is something to that the
background check thing I think there are
some bipartisan support for that raising
the age I think the NRA has a good point
here a lot of these mass shooters that
are underage use their parents weapons
or they find other adults that was the
case in Sandy Hook I'm not sure that
that is going to be a big game changer
but I
think that the mental health issue is a
very very real one there are a lot of
hundreds of millions of guns already out
there we need to make sure they're not
getting into the wrong hands the threat
I also think we need to make sure that
the the FBI and the other intelligence
agencies have protocols in place to
respond to the red flags when we get
them and and and there there was
definitely a failure there in this part
quickly we talked about it all week what
Congress will or won't do all right
mostly on the wall let's look at this
president Trump has a different plan for
the crowd at CPAC than he has earlier in
the week by the time Congress come back
next week I think the president is gonna
stick on school safety and not be
talking about comprehensive background
checks capital C capital B capital C of
which Republicans have no idea what he's
talking about
so until and unless he wants to actually
push for something like a new age
restriction I don't think he's making it
clear what he's really willing to give
on and they are not going to give unless
pushed by this president it is on him to
lead the Republicans they are in an
election year and they are not going to
do this unless he insists on it he
potentially could provide cover if he so
chooses as of today we're not sure what
he's doing